so it's finally time to take a look at
the RTX 4080 and today we're going to
discuss if this thing is actually worth
picking up and it's a heavy one yeah
this will actually launch with the three
slot cooler that you'll also find on the
4090 as far as I can see it's the exact
same design and this is actually the
only 4080 that you need to worry about
for now uh you might have seen at launch
there was a 12 gig and 16 gig that were
announced but after the insane backlash
that Nvidia received regarding the 12
gigabyte model because turns out when
you take a closer look it's actually a
really cut down card and video decided
to I guess recall or revise that product
and you will probably see that coming
out in the future under a different name
or you know different pricing as well
but for now we have the 16 gig model and
that's all we need to worry about right
now but yeah I was pretty surprised to
see such a beefy cooler design for a 320
watt card I guess Nvidia this time
around don't want to like re-engineer a
different cooler design for the lower
TDP like they did for the 3090 and the
3080 and it's funny you put this next
with 3080 it looks like a mammoth of a
GPU also interesting to note whereas the
3080 used a dual 8-pin power adapter the
4080 uses a triple eight pin power
adapter which is one less eight pin from
the 4090 and then taking a look at the
specs the Cuda cores have been bumped up
only slightly compared to previous gen
9728 in total although clock speeds have
seen a huge boost of around 50 percent
then when it comes to the vram it's both
better and worse there's an extra six
gigabytes of video memory on board but
with a Slimmer memory bus width and all
this for an MSRP of 1200 US dollars that
looks pretty alarming next to the 700
price tag of the 3080 but if we're all
honest it was pretty rare to see it
around that price most of the 3080s that
I saw following launch were closer to
the 1 000 USD Mark what is kind of
alarming though is how much more cut
down the 4080 is compared to the 4090
it's definitely not the same story as
previous gen where the 3080 and 3090
were pretty closely matched in terms of
Cuda cores and overall silicon and
especially when it came to gaming
performance here though there is an
enormous difference between the two
which is odd because the pricing is
closer than what it was for the 3080 and
3090 and this Begins the discussion
because if you're already in the market
for a 1200 GPU then surely you're also
in the market for a 1500 GPU you know
it's kind of within the same scope and
if the 1500 product is a measurably
better GPU then maybe it's actually
worth paying extra for to find the
answer to that question of course let's
take a look at performance now quick
note on the test bench here pretty
standard stuff ryzen 5800x 3D with 32
gigabytes of 3600 cl16 memory and a
beefy 1000 watt power supply basically a
super stable bench with no CPU
bottlenecking inside so starting off
with Pure rasterization Performance in
other words gaming without any Ray
tracing or dlss in the mix and yeah the
4080 is a good chunk faster than the
previous previous gen 3080 the games
here aren't going to be as dramatic as
what we saw with the 4090 versus the
3090 but we still see a healthy 60 gain
here or so in Forza Horizon 5. basically
the 4080 can deliver a 4K 120 hertz
experience without any drop in quality
settings pretty comfortably to be honest
that is a warm-up though for the 4090
the Cuda core difference on paper
between these gpus yeah it reflects
pretty accurately when we take a look at
gaming performance as well in Forza
Horizon the 4090 was 36 percent faster
than the new 4080 which isn't bad at all
for 25 more cash similar story in God of
War at 4K Ultra settings the 4080 leaves
the 3080 by a comfortable 50 plus and
the 4090 can almost show that margin
again here it's 40 faster than the 4080.
so evidently there's a pretty big gap
between the 40 90 and 4080 more than
enough to fit a 4080 TI and a 4080 super
as well no doubt the RTX 4080 impressive
but it's also making the 4090 look like
kind of a good deal and then here's a
bit of a generational look on things
we've got the 2080 super versus the 3080
versus the new 4080 without the 4090 in
the picture the 4080 looks ridiculously
quick if you're coming from a 2080 or
2080 super you'd be getting well over
double the FPS by upgrading to the new
RTX 4080 granted you're not CPU
bottlenecked or hitting game engine
limits in the end when we're looking at
pure rasterization gaming performance
without any RTX here's how the 4080
Stacks up against RTX 1390 which is more
of an interesting comparison than you
might think you see when I bought my own
3090 directly after it launched it was
around 2700 AUD and I expect the new
4080 to also land at a similar price on
average here we're looking at around a
34 gain for the new 4080 over the
previous gen 3090 and realistically
that's pretty respectable it's only when
you also include the 4090 in the picture
then we get some additional perspective
so green is now 40 90 and gray is the
4080 and there's basically no
compromising here at 4K for either of
them I think we'd all agree both are
brutally fast and can play games
completely maxed out here no problem
these would look even more Overkill at
1440p so just keep that in mind this is
at 4K Ultra settings but let's just say
that if you're in the market for a beefy
upgrade both the 4080 and 4090 should be
in the picture while the 4080 is
ridiculously quick paying an extra 300
us or 25 more for a 36 buff in frame
rate that's kind of an unheard of gain
when we're looking at Enthusiast tier
gpus what's more typical is paying
hundreds of dollars for a measly 10 or
so that's exactly what we've seen on
previous generations but it's not what
we see here now if you play a lot of
single player games and you're currently
on a 20 series or a 10 series GPU the
new 4080 can do ray tracing and AI
upscaling extremely confidently even at
4K this is really the first generation
of gpus where you don't even have to
think twice about enabling settings and
as far as I've tested and actually
played with them these are actually
beneficial settings that wasn't the
story with the 2080 super which
struggled immensely with first gen RTX
and even with the 3080 you did have to
do some tweaking and playing around to
play at suitable frame rates as you can
see though the 4080 has no problems at
all in addition to the faster gaming
performance overall and the more capable
Ray tracing and AI upscaling it's worth
mentioning a few exclusive features on
the new 4080 and 4090 the first one is a
dlss setting called frame generation
basically what this does is inserts fake
AI generated frames between the actually
rendered ones and the result is a pretty
considerable bump to your frame rate if
you're just playing as you would
normally and passing through the Game
World you actually can't notice these
fake AI frames they just blend in super
well the difference in smoothness though
is definitely noticeable 75 FPS here
versus 105 FPS it's a pretty nice bump
there is unfortunately a slight increase
in latency though when you enable this
setting which you'll fill with
additional input lag it's not a problem
if you're just kicking back and playing
on a controller I'd say in that regard
you can't actually feel it but it is
noticeable if you're playing on mouse
and keyboard and you're really looking
for that input lag difference in my
opinion after testing it and playing
with it it's actually a pretty cool
setting for these really demanding
single player games I just really wish
it was also somehow available for the 30
series and 20 Series gpus in fact side
by side to the 3080 without frame
generation but with Ray tracing and dlss
performance mode on both the new 4080
can basically run with over double the
frame rate which is a really massive
difference it's also worth noting that
frame generation is pretty effective in
delivering frame rates Beyond CPU
bottlenecks so in games like cyberpunk
or flight simulator where your typically
CPU bottlenecked pretty early on this is
a pretty cool setting to break past that
now another exclusive feature that
you'll see on the 40 series gpus is the
Dual envanc encoder setup that can
encode in av1 we looked at this briefly
in the 4090 review but yeah if you're
someone who does game streaming or game
recording this can enable a higher
quality result compared to nvank on
previous gen which can sometimes look
extremely blocky especially at lower bit
rates the 4080 can deliver significantly
better looking footage now the visual
Gap to be fair between h.264 and av1 it
does close the higher bit rate that
you're using but in my comparison so far
every setting side by side av1 has
always looked noticeably better now it's
important to note that shadow play which
is the kind of background recording for
nvidia's gpus that will still record in
h.264 so if you want to make use of the
magic av1 at the moment you'll need to
use ovs so along with dlss frame
generation this is one of the main
exclusive features that you'll see on
the new 40 Ed it'll also enable faster
video exports as well here in DaVinci
Resolve Studio we save a good chunk of
time for a 4K export then if you're
after faster 3D rendering performance
here in blender we get a 44 faster
render time compared to the 3080 which
to be fair is a rendering beast in its
own right at the kind of blistering
speeds that you're seeing here on the 40
series for 3D rendering you can expect
faster viewport performance faster still
renders and much faster renders if
you're doing lengthy stuff like
animations as we mentioned when it came
to gaming though probably also
considered that 40 90 as an option
especially if you're doing this stuff
for work in vra5 here there's actually a
pretty big difference between the two 40
90 here is 45 faster when rendering with
RTX and 40 faster with Cuda in terms of
power consumption and thermals the 4080
is surprisingly good it runs less power
in fact than the 3080 which pretty much
runs at 320 Watts the entire time here
in furmark the 4080 pulled around 300
watts and most of the time in game it
pulls a little bit less than that and
thanks to the beefy triple slot cooler
thermals and noise levels are just not a
problem I left the card running for an
hour here while I went and grabbed some
lunch and it topped out at just 64
degrees C with a room ambient of 23. now
the first question that I asked myself
before making a big Tech upgrade or just
any purchase in general is you know what
does this enable me to do that I
couldn't do previously does it give me a
better experience or does it you know
save me a lot of time or does it make my
life easier in any way uh you know at
least in regards to the first two the 40
series gpus are definitely raising the
bar quite a bit I mean you get
uncompromising 4k gaming performance and
they do have exclusive features the dlss
frame generation and the Dual envanc
encoders they do enable you to do things
that you couldn't do before now it goes
without saying that if you're already on
a 30 series GPU like a 30 70 or a 3080
for example and especially if you're not
interested in those exclusive features
then this is going to be a waste of
money for you you're just not going to
get that benefit of the additional
experience or those exclusive features
and especially if you don't have like a
4k monitor or a high refresh rate 1440p
monitor you're not even going to be able
to see the extra frames that you'd be
getting it is however a pretty colossal
upgrade if you're coming from a 20
series GPU or earlier even if you're
coming from a 2080 TI there's a pretty
meaningful upgrade to be had there
before you even factor in the heavy
stuff like 4K or Ray tracing again
though it is kind of within Arm's Reach
of the 4090 which is a more powerful GPU
so definitely take a look at the pricing
in your region consider what monitor and
power supply you're going to be pairing
with either of them and then maybe make
your decision based off that as well but
yeah 4080 versus 4090 it is a realistic
discussion and the 4090 is oddly the
better pound-for-pound GPU by the looks
of things so far so it goes on sale
tomorrow uh we'll see where the pricing
ends up that's going to be really
interesting versus the 4090 uh but yeah
otherwise hopefully you enjoyed the
review as always a huge thanks for
watching and I'll see you all in the
next one